hello everyone and welcome to a really
fun and easy way to win a lot of games
against aleckin's defense uh it goes E4
Knight to F6 E5 Knight to D5 and now
Knight to F3 Pawn to D6 and now Bishop
the C4 you attack the Knight and the
black will play Knight to B6 which is
the strongest move recommended by the
engine but you don't go back you play
Bishop captures on F7 with check King
captures and now Knight to G5 check King
to G8 only good move for black and now
Pawn to E6 Queen to E8 and now Queen to
F3 and here uh G6 still saves black but
uh uh incredible as it is a lot of the
times black will play H6 and here you
can just deliver the Instant Checkmate
Queen to F7 check Queen captures and the
E captures on F7 will be Checkmate so
incredible but it works a lot of times
I've defeated even 2300 players with
this on leecher so try it let me know
how it goes I hope you enjoyed it